I think that the reason that this
compound did this element nobelium was
named after Nobel is because Nobel is
perhaps the single most famous name that
is associated with science most of the
people that you talk to just in the
street or whatever have probably heard
of Nobel but they may not easily have
heard of Seaborg or some of these other
people so I think as a name from element
it is really quite a good one
the Alfred Nobel was a Swedish chemist
or industrial chemist who worked on
explosives and the problem with
explosives which are compounds of carbon
and nitrogen is that until the time of
Alfred Nobel they were very unstable
they could go off unexpectedly and kill
people in fact I believe one of nobles
relatives might even have been his
brother was killed by a serious
explosion and the reason is that they
these compounds when they start reacting
and the reacting violently the reaction
builds up the heat produced by the first
bit going off goes on so on and what
Nobel discovered his real scientific
discovery was that if he spread this
compound onto an inert material which is
known as Keisel gore it's just
essentially rubble X and that it would
be completely stable you can even throw
it in a fire and it won't explode but if
you use a detonator that produces a
sharp small explosion that is enough to
set the whole lot off and so this
allowed people to handle explosives
safely and many of the developments in
the 19th century the expansion of the
railways and some of the unpleasant
developments in warfare were all brought
about by nobles discovery of these high
explosives that could be stabilized now
the result of this was that no bells
company
became really a very lucrative selling
these explosives and when Nobel died a
foundation was set up which exists to
this day toward prizes in the areas of
science for outstanding science in
physics in medicine and chemistry and
economics and peace and I think the
economics may actually be given by a
sister organization and each year the
prize is announced for really one of the
most exciting pieces of chemistry that
has been done in the preceding few years
occasionally it for something that was
done just a year or two before where
everybody recognizes straight away it
was revolutionary for example the
discovery of c60 the molecule with 60
carbon atoms that looks like a football
was rewarded really quite quickly other
prizes
you really have to wait to see how the
field develops and to see whether this
discovery really was important whether
it really changes the field of chemistry
is every chemists dream to win a Nobel
Prize I suppose so but there's there's
just only three people can win it each
year and there's so many chemists that
it's really something which is almost
like a lottery in fact some national
lotteries it's probably easier to win
the prize so I think most chemists
really aspired to becoming members of
the National Academy of Sciences of
their own country and most of them don't
think of winning the Nobel Prize
so nobelium and nobelium is perhaps best
known for the fact that it is quite
controversial in terms of its naming so
it was originally discovered and called
nobelium and then another research group
disputed these findings but then claims
that they made it and they gave it a
different name but then eventually
because it had been named as nobelium
for such a long time people eventually
just settled on that
but he had nothing to do with nobelium
but no no no nobelium was discovered
although the first detected I'm not sure
how many years but probably nearly am
probably nearly a century after his
death